مدينة نيويورك تغرق، لا تخطر
ببالك بسرعة، ولكن
مع ذلك تفكر في بحث جديد يقول إن
مزيج ناطحات السحاب الضخمة وارتفاع
مستوى المحيط يهدد تهديد جوثام،
تقرير بيل وير من بروكلين،
لدينا الآن إجابة على السؤال الذي لا
بد أن يسألك طفلك عن مقداره
هل تزن مدينة نيويورك 1.7 تريليون
رطل كما نعرف الآن حيث أن
ناطحات السحاب في هذه المدينة تبدو
أطول كل عام ولكن الأهم
من هذا الرقم هو أكثر من
تريليون طن من التلوث المروري الحراري
الذي وضعته البشرية في رؤيتها
السماء في الـ 150 عامًا الماضية والتي تؤدي
بالطبع إلى ذوبان القطبين وتسبب في
ارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر ببطء ولكن بثبات، لذا فإن
نيويورك إلى جانب العديد من المدن الساحلية
حول العالم تنحسر قليلاً عن
مستوى سطح البحر آخذ في الارتفاع ولهذا السبب يقولون إن
المدن الساحلية سترتفع  كن
أكثر عرضة لارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر بثلاث إلى أربع مرات
مقارنة بالأماكن الأكثر استقرارًا التي يمكنك سماعها
في الخلفية الموسيقى الجميلة كاليوب
لجين كاروسيل، هذا
أحد أحياء دامبو في بروكلين وأولئك
الذين تعود ذكرياتهم إلى تسع
سنوات قد تتذكرون العاصفة الفائقة  ساندي
التي دمرت هذه الواجهة البحرية على طول
النهر الشرقي، كان ارتفاع الأمواج ثمانية أقدام
مقابل الزجاج هنا،
نجت ولكن الآن بعد تسع سنوات،
يقومون بدعم ضفة النهر، شاهدوا
البارجة هناك مع كل الصخور الموجودة
عليها، هذا جزء من Revenant  البرنامج
الذي بدأ للتو عملية
تحصين مدينة نيويورك ضد ارتفاع
البحار، لدى فيلق مهندسي الجيش
عدد من السيناريوهات المختلفة
لبناء جدار بحري بمليارات الدولارات،
ومشاريع طويلة لعدة عقود لمحاولة
حماية المركز المالي
لمانهاتن بالطبع.  موانئ الشحن على
جانب جيرسي أيضًا والشيء الآخر
المثير للاهتمام مع ارتفاع درجة حرارة الكوكب
يبدو أن قص الرياح الطبيعي الذي
كان يستخدم لحماية مدينة نيويورك من
الأعاصير يختفي، لذا
ترتفع فرص حدوث عاصفة خارقة أخرى ساندي مع
ارتفاع درجة الحرارة  التوقعات هي أن
ارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر يمكن أن يتراوح من
سبع بوصات إلى قدمين بحلول عام 2050 وهو
ليس بعيدًا.
والفرق الوحيد في ذلك هو مقدار
تلوث الوقود الأحفوري الذي تضعه البشرية في
السماء وهذا هو المفتاح الذي
يتحكم في هذا  حركة درجة الحرارة
الآن ولكن في هذه الأثناء، إنه
يوم جميل لن تعرف أن مكانًا
مثل هذا يتحرك تدريجيًا ولكن هذه
هي قوة البشرية هذه الأيام في
عصر الأنثروبوسين